[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
max tegmark and it's a great honor to
welcome you all to the 2020
future of life awards where we're going
to celebrate
two amazing people who've helped save
about 200 million lives
and to help us celebrate we're gonna
hear from a bunch of fascinating people
from bill gates we're gonna we're gonna
hear from anthony fauci
jennifer doudna and we're gonna have
lots of great discussions
we're gonna start up in earnest in
a couple of minutes and before then i
would love it if you
out there on facebook live on youtube
live
and on zoom can type in your chat where
you are right now
and while you do that we're also going
to have some really interesting
discussions and
if there's something you would like me
to bring up
during this discussion and ask our
awesome
guests please type it here in the chat
so i can see you
i see we have the the kai and hong kong
we have car
oh it's going by so fast it's hard to
see my old
friend gustavreed in stockholm we got
greetings from munich
germany warm welcome to all of you
from around the world and again don't
forget to
tell us also about things that you would
like us to talk about
and i'm so glad to see we have a lot of
people from russia here as well
where we are going to have to help honor
one of your great countrymen who's done
great things
we're going to start in earnest in about
one minute before that
i want to tell you all out there how you
can help us
in the future because even though we do
a very scientific
and rigorous vetting process of course
to select the winners each year
the winners we start vetting are only as
good as the winners we know about
and we have a crowdsourced nomination
process where all of you
can nominate people and bring them to
our attention
and if your nominee wins the prize a
year from now
we even show our gratitude by giving you
three thousand dollars you can find more
about this
on our website and in fact the two
the winners we're going to have today
were both nominated by
people like you out there so
great thanks for that so without further
ado
for those of you who just joined on
facebook live youtube live
and zoom again i'm max tegmark and it's
my great honor
to welcome you to the 2020
future of life awards where we're gonna
honor
these two amazing people today
so this
ceremony this award that we're giving
out
you might think what's another award
there's so many awards you can win the
oscars for making great movies
you can win medals for running really
fast
you can win nobel prizes for doing great
science in fact
we have someone who has done just that
yesterday who's with us today
why do we need another one well we feel
that there should also be an award for
those
unsung heroes who have done incredibly
great things
for humanity but many people haven't
heard of or much less famous
than your average hollywood actor to
give you a flavor of this let me tell
you who's won so far
in 2017 the future of life award went to
vasily arkhipov
single-handedly prevented a soviet
nuclear nuclear attack on u.s
forces and we're so honored to have his
very own daughter yelena
with us live today from moscow trivia
tillena
and a warm welcome to you if it weren't
for your father he probably would not be
here
that was a tough fact to follow but the
following year
stanislav petrov got the future life
award
for helping avert another nuclear war in
1983 when the soviet early warning
center that he was in charge of
saw five incoming american nuclear
missiles
and we're very grateful
that he was the guy in charge that day
the following year the award went to
professor matthew messelson just down
the road from where i am
here at mit down at harvard for
his incredible contributions to uh
getting biological weapons
banned and for avoiding an arms race in
bioweapons and this is why
today we think of biology as a force for
good
for developing covad vaccines and for
saving lives rather than for taking
lives many of my friends
got really worried about this and said
hey you've set impossible standards for
the future life award this is just an
impossible act
to follow but i'm really delighted that
today we are going to prove them wrong
by introducing you to two other
truly truly worthy winners so
let's roll the video
imagine how you'd react to the headline
mutated coronavirus discovered
killing 30 percent of those infected
smallpox was such a lethal virus
estimated to have killed 500 million
people
in its last century but a massive
international team effort defeated
smallpox
completely eradicating it and unicef
estimates that this has saved close to
200 million lives so far
today to celebrate the 41st anniversary
of the official eradication of smallpox
we grant the future of life award to two
heroes critically contributed to this
victory
bill feige and victor zdanov
viktor's donov has been called the best
person who ever lived
by oxford professor will mccaskill for
successfully persuading the world health
organization
to initiate an eradication campaign
where the united states
and the soviet union teamed up despite
the cold war
while serving as the soviet union's
deputy minister of health
victor zhanov persuaded naysayers both
at home and abroad
that the world could and should
eradicate smallpox with a united effort
and arranged for the soviet union to
donate 25 million doses
of smallpox vaccine to kickstart the
effort
in developing countries the world health
organization accepted his proposal in
1959
and he lived to see smallpox officially
eradicated
in 1979. he passed away in 1987
and his award will be received by his
sons victor janov
and michael bukrinsky in his memory
eradicating smallpox required not only
audacity
but also solving the problem of
insufficient resources for vaccinating
everyone
while working for the center of disease
control in africa
as chief of the smallpox eradication
program
bill fakie developed a highly successful
surveillance
and ring vaccination strategy which has
been described as applying water to the
house on fire
rather than the whole neighborhood this
greatly reduced the number of
vaccinations needed
ensuring that the limited resources
available suffice
to make smallpox the first infectious
disease
to be eradicated in human history
bill feige and victor donov are true
heroes
who remind us of the power of science
and international collaboration for
tackling coven 19
and future health challenges thank you
both
yes thank you both i'm tearing up here
because it's so moving what what you
have accomplished
if there were a nobel prize for saving
lives
you would both have won it and and so
would vasily archibald
stanley stanislav
and if it were not for the collective
acts of all of you
i would probably not be alive right now
and the same probably goes for most of
you
listening to this so it's a really great
honor to get to bestow
the future life award today to
dr bill feige and dr viktor stanov
thanks to the amazing generosity of jan
talin
one of the founders of the future of
life institute you will be
sharing a hundred thousand dollars and
also
it is my great honor to give you
something personal
right now to hold on to so
it's a great honor for me to first of
all give that 2020
future of life a word to
dr bill feige
see our little mit particle transmutator
through space time
worked congratulations
can you unmute bill feige their
producers
or maybe we're on it we got it
congratulations
so thank you max for the honor
for the plaque and for the exceptional
science
that allowed you to transmit this to me
thank you very much
our pleasure and it is similarly
enormous honor to give the future life
award
to the late viktors donov and we're so
delighted to have
you here dr michael buclinski
to receive this plaque
oh this one went inside it's it's hard
to pull it
off the internet actually but uh
thank you so much max and it's a great
honor
wonderful and we and finally the third
plaque
it's a great honor to get
to give it to to give this to dr viktor
stonov
jr
amazing what some quantum teleportation
can do congratulations
all yeah thank you very much i'm very
proud of it
thank you and we are very proud
max we uh lost your audio max we lost
your audio
all right go ahead and speak again can
you hear me now
yes we can hear you now all right so
congratulations
again we now turn to celebrating
our winners and first let's hear from
bill gates
i'm sorry i can't be with you to honor
two true heroes of global health
victor sandonov and bill faye
with the future of life award they're
phenomenal examples of what it means to
harness science for public health
the eradication of smallpox not only
prevented
unnecessary suffering and death it
showed the world that diseases can be
defeated
and it reminds us of the need for global
cooperation in fighting other diseases
such as covet 19 malaria
polio and diseases we have yet to
encounter
i've never had the pleasure of meeting
dr donov but the more i learn about his
accomplishments the more i respect his
work
he played a leading role in getting
rival superpowers
to team up against smallpox
i do have the pleasure of knowing bill
faye
it's fair to say he was my first teacher
in global health
bill was one of the first people melinda
and i turned to when we began learning
about the subject
and he's had a huge influence on us
we wanted to understand what it took to
eradicate diseases
so he turned to one of the people who'd
had actually
done it he gave me a list of about 80
books and journals to read
and i looked at all of them one
important thing i learned from that
assignment
was how much more i needed to learn
luckily bill has been there as helping
us every step of the way
also sharing his knowledge wisdom and
passion
he also has more memorable quotes from
ancient writers than any other person i
know
bill has set a phenomenal example for
everyone who cares about global health
as a physician teacher leader and
advocate for acting on the idea
that all lives have equal value
congratulations again
to bill and to the family of dr
sadanov and thank you all for your
continuing efforts
to save lives around the world
yes thank you from all of us and to
continue the
the celebrations uh we're now
going to turn to it a fun discussion
with uh
dr jennifer doudna and dr anthony fauci
and uh first of all is it okay if i
called
you simply jennifer and tony
good good so my first question to you
jennifer is
what was in how did you guys pull off
the the nobel prize ceremony
yesterday without upsetting
tony with poor social distancing
well it went through a few different
planning stages
and ended up happening outdoors on my
patio
in berkeley california and uh
i think everybody here would be pleased
to know that it was a
lovely event very small very safe
everybody masked and distanced but
still really meaningful i think to all
of us
as a celebration of science so we're all
looking nervously at you tony uh do you
approve oh absolutely
[Laughter]
yes i mean uh given the circumstances in
which the world is right now
um the kind of honor that was given to
jennifer for her extraordinary
scientific accomplishment
could not be put off so in the spirit of
improvisation
what they did was to do it in a way that
was totally safe but nonetheless
extraordinarily meaningful so she gets
an a plus
for public health wonderful huge
congratulations to you jennifer not only
on winning the nobel prize that was the
easy part but for getting an a
plus from tony fauci
so let me first ask each of you maybe
you can you can start jennifer
if there's anything you want any
congratulations that you want to pass
along
to the winners well i i
certainly uh i certainly am in awe
of your work it's extraordinary
i think that you know the the example of
the smallpox
eradication effort is one that we all
look to as a model for what can be
achieved
in in global public health it's truly
amazing
and boy it couldn't be more relevant
this year in 2020
when we find ourselves in the middle of
a global pandemic
and i hope on the verge of eradicating
that virus that's causing it the cyrus
cov2 virus
with emerging vaccines and i hope we get
into a little bit of a discussion about
that because i think it's a
it's a really exciting opportunity we
have in front of us but also a really
big challenge
great so what about you tony do you want
to
is there anything particular you want to
convey to the to the winners or about
them
yeah well thank you max well you know as
a person who's been
involved in infectious diseases now for
for several decades um
i'm just thrilled to be here uh with you
today
to pay honor to victor and and
bill um i never met uh
dr zanoff but um bill feige has been
a friend and an inspiration not only to
me
but to virtually every other public
health official
who has tackled any serious problem he's
become
together with victor the gold standards
of what is achievable
i mean the the massive undertaking
of taking one of the most devastating
diseases in the history
of civilization and not only controlling
it
not only eliminating it but actually
eradicating it
is really stands as the standard as
jennifer said
of what we hope to do with other
diseases with polio
with measles and ultimately i hope
with saw's coronavirus too so you set a
high standard and hopefully
some of us will meet it in the future
wonderful so
one big question i have here is
reflecting on this triumph aside from
celebrating it is
what is it that we can learn from it
what lessons
did can we draw from these great
successes
both the political ones of viktor's
donovan
getting all this international
collaboration going between
rivaling superpowers to do better global
health and also on the scientific side
and
in terms of the management what lessons
are that are relevant today
for example uh tony are there anything
any lessons here that you
you feel are relevant to uh fighting
covet
well yes max you alluded a bit to to a
couple of them i think one of the most
important
is when you're dealing with a global
health challenge you've got to attack it
at a global
level and what bill and what victor
did was to really establish that there
are no
boundaries there are the globe that we
live on
smallpox was a disease that afflicted
society they teamed up in what appeared
at the time to be
divisive and competing superpowers
there's no secret that we live in a
divisive world
right now we live even in the country in
which we're all sitting right now at
least some of us
in the united states is very divisive
and we're dealing with one of the most
historic outbreaks
that have occurred in the last 100 years
dating back to 1918 so there are many
lessons to be learned
that as enormous as the problem is you
can encounter it
and you can overcome it the way bill and
victor did
despite the fact that politically
you were in very problematic
circumstances so i think it's almost
eerily similar when you talk about the
differences of what we're doing now
and what bill and victor did decades ago
yeah feel free to chime in uh
you too bill and uh
you too michael if you have reflections
on this and what what we
should what we should learn from from
this if there's anything
yeah i just wanted to say that um
victor was never awarded
any kind of prize or anything in the
soviet union
for his accomplishments in uh in
eradicating smallpox that's amazing
and the reason probably was that
smallpox at that time was not uh
such a you know major uh
medical problem in in soviet union
uh it was a problem in in underdeveloped
world
and that's that even makes it uh
in my view even more kind of
significant that victor at that time
uh spent all his efforts and uh
his uh this was actually his lifelong
efforts to
engage international scientific uh
cooperation
to fight this uh you know problem
uh around the world
i'm so delighted also to have so many
participants from around the world
making this a very international
celebration right now and and
what we just heard there but really
collaborating internationally and
including the developing world that
sounds very much like
you bill like what you spent so much of
your work
doing do you want to comment on on any
of the lessons learned as well
in your mind thank you max first uh
jennifer congratulations to you
and it was a pleasure to have bill gates
make his statement because i've said
this many times
when the history of global health is
finally written
we'll find that the year 2000 was a
tipping point
and it was because of the gates family
getting
involved in global health and
tony thank you so much for being here
a friend of yours asked me if i would
find out what you've been doing this
last year
and so maybe we could talk about that
later but in the meantime
let me just say that tony has turned out
to be
the ultimate scientist
huxley once said that science is simply
common sense
at its best and tony has provided that
every day the common sense that it's
best even when there's
a lot of noise around this
untruths going around and so forth
the the other thing i'd like to say
about tony if i recall correctly tony
you are driving to your first day as an
infectious disease resident
when you heard on the radio the surgeon
general of the united states declaring
the end of infectious diseases
and you wonder what in the world am i
doing it shows you the
the problem with the predictions but
the the question of of what have we
learned i think
one of the single biggest lessons that i
learned
is that if you're going to do not only
the eradication of disease but any
scientific endeavor there are three
things that have to come together one is
the science
and people outside of science think we
really know what's happening but
i'm reminded of the fact that richard
feynman said uncertainty
is the basis of science he said in fact
certainty is the achilles heel
of science and people see science as
being
truth but it's actually just a way of
finding
getting as close to certainty and as
close to truth
as we can and then when you look at the
huxley quote of
that it's common sense that it's best
that's one of the three things that
one has to to think about second
will durant said if you add art to
science
you now bring creativity into this so
you have
creative common sense at its best
and he used as his example immotep
the egyptian physician who was also an
artist who designed and built the step
pyramid and then for the third part of
this
i go back to roger bacon 700 years ago
who did a report for the pope
and he came out with three summary
statements
but one of them was science has no
moral compass therefore
you need scientists with a moral compass
and if you put this all together you're
talking about creative
moral common sense at its best and
that's a great foundation for any
science endeavor and that seems like a
wonderful description of both the
victorianov and bill feige also that
goes like a red thread
throughout their work i've very much
enjoyed
reading uh reading bill's book which i
would highly recommend
anyone who wants to learn more about
smallpox eradication
house on fire and
well you can see all these three things
and uh there is also a book that has
never been published in the english
language
about viktor janov
which is written by his late wife so to
help honor him we have had it translated
now
into english for the very first time and
on the award website
we're putting it there as a free pdf
download absolutely
fascinating reading where i think again
those very three traits that you just
mentioned there
shine through loud and clear as we'll
continue talking about
later today at a personal level also i i
almost teared up here when you talked
about how how the
foundation of science is not certainly
but uncertainty because
quoted my great physics hero richard
feynman because
when people ask me sometimes to define
science
to me it's all about embracing
uncertainty
i to me being a scientist really means
that i would rather have
questions i can't answer than answers i
can't question
and um so
the before we move on from from this
question about what lessons we learned
let me
throw it out to all four of you again uh
jennifer tony
michael build to see if there's anything
more you would like to add on this
fascinating topic
there are two things max that i would
add i think the second
lesson is the lesson of tenacity
tenacity doesn't always win but it's the
only thing that does win
and when you think of victor coming up
with his idea in 1958
which was presented in minneapolis
most world health assemblies are held in
geneva
but this one was held in minneapolis so
he was doing it on u.s
ground proposing a smallpox eradication
program
and he did that every year at the
world health assembly until finally he
was agreed to put some money into it so
tenacity
is very important the third lesson
though would be
to actually learn the lessons because
i see tony every day not only fighting
coronavirus
but fighting people who are not
observing the lessons of the past what
we've learned which
you need to know the truth you need
coalitions you need
a national plan you need to work
globally
and so tony's been up against both
a virus and misconceptions
on how to proceed with the program so
it's a double task for him so tony
let me ask you what lessons we should
learn
from you then what is your secret how do
you manage to stay so true
to these ideals of common sense
compassionate science
despite all sorts of pressures from all
directions
what can you teach the rest of us well i
think it was just mentioned
a little bit ago what i try to do
is focus like a laser beam on what
my purpose and what my end game is
and that is right now in the middle of
an outbreak
um the health and the safety of the
american
people driven by evidence-based
science i mean just what we've been
talking about
here today that science
leads us to the development of policies
that are directed to the preservation of
the health and the safety of the
american public
everything else max is noise and you've
got to take it for what it
is it's distracting noise
once you get caught up in the
distracting noise
you get diverted and distracted
from what your main goal is so you've
got to be able to focus and just say to
yourself
you know sometimes this is offensive and
you want to hit back
and sometimes somebody's insulting you
and
saying that you're crazy just put it
aside and
focus and stay with the science and
actually it's not that complicated to do
because it's pretty clear when you see
data and truth that we're talking about
today
that leads you to the development of
policies
you make it sound so easy tony but we
all know that it's actually
very hard to not get distracted by the
noise especially when it's
personal ad hominem and really
really really distracting noise do you
have any personal
techniques you can recommend to the rest
of us for just
doing what you actually said and
retaining focus nonetheless
well i go back to one of my favorite
movies
the godfather part one where they said
it's nothing personal it's strictly
business
don't take it personal
i have learned something great today
tony thank you so much
for that but it's still max it's worth
mentioning
that tony was able to remain
a public servant while many people then
became private servants
they started out as public servants but
they could not withstand the pressure
and they became private servants
and we're all very grateful for that so
so let us shift gears now from
reflecting on lessons from the past to
talking about the future
to me one thing that stands out
about the smallpox eradication
aside from the fact that it's already
according to estimates saved
about 2 100 million lives and
continues saying living lives every year
when it passes without any deaths
aside from the sheer goodness of it
another thing that really stands out is
the sheer audacity of it
right that's why it was so remarkable
for example that that viktor's done
was able to nonetheless sell this and
persuade people to
cry for this ultimate moonshot and even
both the audacity of the science of
eradicating this horrible disease and
the audacity of thinking that you could
get the soviet union
and the united states to work together
on something during the cold war
so my question for the future looking to
the future is
can we also be if we get inspired by
this audacity
what other truly audacious
public health goals for public health
for medical science
are there out there now that you would
like us to see
take on uh let me start maybe with you
jennifer
well i certainly think you know going
back to the example of the
the smallpox eradication the goal
of of um vaccinating the world
against the coronavirus is a big one and
an immediate one
that we're facing and i do think that
there's a there's a big challenge ahead
but it's also an incredible opportunity
and it's an opportunity not only
in global public health but also in
education and
kind of furthering the you know the view
that i think many of us
here certainly would share which is was
articulated beautifully by
uh tony fauci that you know that that
you know science
you know is uh you know we need to rely
on evidence-based
science as we make public health
decisions not
on not on speculation or fears or
or uh you know various
various kinds of uh made up imagine
imagined uh stories but really on
the best evidence that we have right now
for
a circumstance we find ourselves in such
as this pandemic so i
certainly think that's that's an
immediate goal and then beyond that
um you know i i personally think that uh
we're facing uh
another i think equally
important uh you know or equally
global emergency if you think about the
challenge we face with
with uh climate change and i you know
you might
say well wait a minute does that what
does that have to do with medicine or
public health i think it has everything
to do with it
and i'd really like to see all of us as
scientists
uh think about how we're going to
address this
and use our our expertise and our work
to
do what we can to deal with i think what
is
is truly an existential threat to to all
of us
that's are very good points
smallpox did not respect borders
carbon dioxide also blows right across
borders
nuclear winter doesn't respect borders
so many of these great challenges
uh are truly global challenges and and
taking them on we
we can we can be inspired by this
audacity that we've
seen in
today's guest of honor here bill feige
and victor donna
tony what about you if you were to pick
out a few moonshots they're truly
audacious
that you would like us to to take on
ideally
again as global collaborations what's on
your
top list you know max there are a couple
there there are finishing
um things that have been started that
are still doable
i'm very frustrated as an infectious
disease person
that we have not yet eradicated two
diseases that are
eminently eradicatable and that is polio
we were almost there
almost and then we slipped a bit as a
as a global community but i think we can
get back
on track and do polio the other
is the common disease of measles
you know um i learned from bill
many years ago from things he's written
that there's
control there's elimination and there's
eradication
you know and we've controlled and
eliminated to many respects
measles for example in many of the
developing countries but we have not yet
eradicated it
but it is eminently eradicatable and i
think we need to continue
to not give up on that effort
so those are two of the things that i
think we need
to aim at the other is something that is
also
you know audacious and bold but it's
something we should not
um give up on is that to have throughout
the world
health systems that are
achievable and available to everyone
throughout the world i mean if we could
build up
local global health systems so that
people in developing countries do not
suffer
and in some cases die from diseases that
are so easily taken
care of in the developed world i you
know i just have felt always
that we have a moral responsibility
those of us who live
in rich countries to share
that wealth in the sense of providing
for developing countries
some of the things that's impossible for
them to do on their own
you don't want to make welfare states of
everyone but you got to help people to
do things that they can't do on their
own
so those are three things that i think
we can look forward to in the coming
decades
that's very inspiring the thing you said
there about helping the developing world
of course also is a great way to
celebrate
victor donovan bill feige because of
course the rich countries had already
been vaccinating their populations for
quite a while
and it was the the final amazing push
was precisely to help the rest of the
world
get up to that same level and maybe you
if if you could also just say a couple
of words to help those who are listening
here
understand why it was even though people
who are listening they've heard of so
many diseases and they might wonder why
are you picking just measles and polio
do you want to say something about the
human-only transmission yeah
all right well that's a very good point
mac max
there are certain characteristics that
you have to have uh
if you want to eradicate uh an
infectious disease from the planet
and if it has a reservoir in another
species
it becomes extremely difficult if not
impossible
to do which is one of the reasons why a
disease like ebola
may be very difficult to do because
there are reservoirs all over the place
with ebola
particularly in central in central
africa the other
thing is the ingredient that you have a
highly
efficacious and effective vaccine
and that's what we have for both of them
the measles vaccine
is the gold standard of efficacy
it's about 98 effective
you achieve herd immunity by getting
90 or more of the population vaccinated
once you do that measles will disappear
and the same holds true for polio
thank you so much let me ask uh
also you michael and um
you bill if michael do you have any any
moonshots any really audacious things
you would like to see yeah i i actually
wanted
to ask tony uh about uh
about coronavirus because he mentioned
that uh lack of animal reservoir for
those
uh polio and uh and
measles is a kind of
factor that allows elimination but what
about
coronavirus which has a very wide
reservoir animal reservoir can we
eliminate that one
i think michael that we can for the
following reason
that i believe given what we know
of the commonality of spike proteins
which are the major
antigen or immunogen in a vaccine for
coronaviruses
that it is attainable for us to develop
what we call a universal
coronavirus vaccine namely a vaccine
that is not only effective
against the common cold coronaviruses of
which there are four
effective against the three known
pandemic coronaviruses sars
mares and now saws coronavirus two
but any coronavirus that might actually
emerge
in the future because there is a large
bat
reservoir for coronaviruses but if you
can vaccinate the world
with a universal coronavirus vaccine you
could even
prevent it ever from becoming a public
health hazard
thank you michael you are a very
successful
researcher yourself on hiv
so do you think there might be any hope
one day of also
making hiv extinct
yeah i was actually waiting for tony to
to mention it but
he didn't and uh i agree that
that may be a long shot that it's really
a very
difficult uh task uh simply because hiv
is a chronic disease
it's kind of it's very difficult to but
i believe that
uh if we if we kind of
use the technology and in particular
this
jennifer's uh kind of crispr
uh based uh technology to
uh which would allow us to
really eliminate the virus from the
from the infected people and uh
eventually i think it would be possible
to
uh to get
this infection from the human population
of course this virus again it it exists
in
in animals and in in in monkeys
so but uh but
maybe at some day we will have a vaccine
that again
would prevent transmission and infection
so i i i think that
hiv can can be added to this future
kind of hopes uh of uh
elimination of infectious diseases
wonderful and in about one minute
we're gonna do uh what
in soccer is called a substitution we're
gonna let
anthony farci go off and continue
helping us with
you know what and replace him with
another awesome panelist but i want to
first give you a chance anthony to get
the last word in this segment here
is there anything more you want to add
oh yes i i i want to just express my
appreciation for
giving me the opportunity to participate
uh
over this uh hour 45 minutes
with two extraordinary heroes um
in a uh in an arena in which i
work every single day i mean there's
something about
having heroes that you can look up to
and certainly
uh victor and bill are two of those
individuals also to have the opportunity
to be on the panel with with jennifer
and to congratulate her again on
an extraordinary accomplishment for
which she was so
deservedly awarded the nobel prize
yesterday
well thank you and as you heard you
yourself are of course also a hero who's
inspired so many here
so thank you so much and and keep doing
with
what you do so well and don't let all
the noise get to you
thank you very much so much tony real
pleasure
bye-bye and now we will welcome to this
conversation none other than
professor matthew meselson from harvard
university
last year's future life award winner who
as as i'm
hey matthew it's so great to see you i
think
you need to unmute yourself there
and uh if i'm half as energetic
at 60 here you are
such a pleasure to have you with us can
you hear me
loud and clear very good i should
explain why i'm wearing this mask
it's because dentistry has caused a very
temporary hematoma which i don't want
you to have to suffer to see
otherwise it's a trivial thing but i do
need to wear the mask
to protect you there is something i
would like to say i don't know if this
is the right time max i don't want to
intrude on other things oh please do
please do all right
so there's certainly justifiable concern
for what are called existential threats
that involve mass destruction of
environment or of human life
and also for threats that
might occur in the near future
but it's very difficult to think
productively about things that might
happen
in the distant future or things that
happen or accrue
only very gradually we all know that
we're evolved to deal with imminent
threats
but not to deal very well with long-term
threats
so the thing i want to mention is that
not only is it important to protect
human life
what you are celebrating today
but it's also important to think about
because i don't know how to do it yet
to protect what it means to be human
what it means to be in other words to
protect our humanity one could imagine
that our species in some evolved form
because
evolution is not stopping it's
proceeding
with some manifestation of our species
or
a species that might in a long period of
time branch off from it
would be thriving very healthy
in a very nice environment but would
have lost
some of the attributes that we value
most
how do you deal with this kind of a
question i hardly know
one of the things would be first to just
discuss
and particularly with students because
they're the people who will
be in positions to influence the
dialogue of the future and decisions of
the future
to discuss what do we value most in
humanity is it
curiosity is it kindness
is it compassion is it the ability to
sit down
purely with mathematical concepts
develop them and then
find out for everyone's astonishment
that they tell you what the physical
world
is like that's what einstein is just one
example did
he sat down and worked with what are
called tensors and other mathematical
formulations following the rules of the
mass and got general relativity
and now we detect uh signals from
gravitational waves caused by black
holes
colliding so what maybe there are other
things
so i know i have however i am worried
about one thing
and this is in jennifer's promise of
course
and that is not today not tomorrow not
in any of our lifetimes
but if it ever becomes common practice
to manipulate the human genome
which i'm sure will happen i hope that
when it does happen
we know enough about something with
regard to which we know nothing now
which is what is it inside of this box
that makes us human yeah thank you so
much
for this perfect perfect uh i wanted to
say one more thing about that
and that is that i know enough about
this to know that off-target effects
are not going to be a serious problem
that can be dealt with
i am concerned and this is directed to
jennifer
with epistatic interactions because we
know almost nothing
about i don't want to get too technical
here i've written about it
but we know almost nothing about how the
product of one gene
interacts with the products of other
genes
so that in modifying the product of one
gene
an ignorance of how it might interact
with other genes
which is called epistasis uh who knows
exactly what kind of deep waters might
get
into so there needs to be more study
of the humanities more asking what makes
us human
eventually we'll know up here it's all
up here got to be there
so that not only modification of the
human genome but also
possibly if we uh if we enter
if we entrust too much of our humanity
to machines
i mean advanced intelligent machines
if we do too much in trusting i would
call it entrusting because in principle
we should always have the ability to
pull it back but that too might have
long-term effects on
what it means to be human yeah matthew
let me jump in here matthew and thank
you so much again for
first segueing into exactly what we want
to focus the remainder of this
conversation on
and before we we hear from about
epistemic
interactions from from jennifer and so
on
just to frame this at the higher level
what we want to focus on
is exactly this looking farther into the
future now
biotechnology and so on will obviously
continue
growing ever more powerful how can we
steer it
in a good direction towards great uses
like eradicating smallpox and the other
diseases that we heard about earlier
and away from bad uses such as humanity
let me just finish here you're rather
biological
that you helped us get banned and and
and
other things so it i wanted to first
first ask you here jennifer
so you you in terms of this steering
challenge
you wrote this very interesting piece in
the economist recently
where you actually made some quite
concrete proposals
for what we should do do you want to do
you want to share a little bit about
that with the rest of us
well i i certainly agree with what matt
meselson just articulated we absolutely
need to be
thinking about how to integrate science
with a broader perspective on what it
means to be human
and how do we do that it's a big
challenge um
i personally think that it has to
involve all of us
who are practicing scientists being a
lot more engaged
than we maybe have been in the past
in these conversations and um you know i
saw an interesting twitter thread this
morning
that reflected i think what many
people unfortunately uh think of
scientists which is not flattering
and you know they think about scientists
as people who are
are a bit smug maybe a bit um you know
self-involved and and not inclusive
in our views of the world and our our
incorporation of other
you know other sort of non-uh
non-scientists
in thinking about the future of science
and technology so
i'd really like to see that become a
much more commonplace thing i think it
was true
in the in the past historically that
science was
far more integrated into society and you
know dinner table conversations than
maybe it is now
so i think we all have a part to play
there
and uh and i think also as matt meselson
said i agree that it has to it has to be
the
uh the focus of our our students they
are the future
and they're the future of everything and
so we really need to encourage our
students to be
more inclusive in their thinking rather
than getting too siloed in particular
areas of science thinking
about it in a more integrated way and it
is a big challenge but i think that's
something that honestly the future of
life institute
is well positioned to do thank you for
that yeah this is of course the whole
reason we created the future of life
institute because
we love technology but technology is not
good it's also not evil it's a tool and
we wanted work to steer it towards good
uses
like eradicating small box and
away from the ones that you matthew have
worked so hard to
to put kibosh on and i want to just give
a shout out here to victor john of
himself also because
the book that has never been read in
english before that we had translated
and is on the website now
my wife and i had a lot of fun reading
it just over the past few nights here
and it was
so touching to see that he was
very much the soviet version of matthew
meselson in in 1960 in 1968 he spent
two months learning spanish just so we
could go to a conference
in mexico and give a speech in spanish
about why we should ban bioweapons
it was really remarkable and uh in
uh and much much later he when he
discovered to his horror
you can read about this again in this
book which we can download for free
that his deputy and his institute that
he ran had secretly been
developing bioweapons behind his back he
immediately fired him
and made a big stink about it and uh
he this was clearly something he was
very very very
uh passionate about i want to ask you
bill
a little bit also the same question if
you think about the future
all the great things that we can do with
biology and biotech
and the things we should avoid what are
the things you
feel most strongly we have to be careful
to avoid and do you have any
any recommendations for how we can keep
our moral compass working
thank you max first i would repeat some
of the things that we heard i think
the biggest problems that we face are
problems that would lead to the
extinction of humans
and there are three or four big ones
we've heard a little bit about
each one but global warming is one
nuclear weapons is the second one
artificial intelligence i think is a
third one and i think synthetic biology
is a fourth one so we should be putting
a lot of attention
on the things that could actually cause
the extinction
of humans a second area that i would
think about
is this area that tony brought up of
equity
and twinbe the historian
said the 20th century will be remembered
for the time when we got
equity in health around the world he was
absolutely wrong
we ended the century with such a gap
but i think we now have tools
we have the ability to narrow that gap
so
equity in various things health would be
one
education would be another the ability
for people to thrive so that's an area
and then i would go to the third area
that tony was talking about
there are specific diseases that we
could eliminate right now
and i agree with him that polio and
measles are two of them a guinea worm
is close to eradication but without a
vaccine
so we shouldn't limit eradication to
infectious diseases
i think we should be thinking about
chemicals and other things
that are harmful and how would we
eradicate them
i think the future in this is very
difficult because of what we call
asymmetry
that it's possible for a person or a
small group of people
to actually hold an entire country or
the entire world at hostage
with their science and technology and so
on the one hand i think continue
to reward people who are using science
and technology
correctly and then we need a
real surveillance system to detect
when people are doing something that
could cause great harm
to to lots of people but i take
some comfort from how we see this
happening
in crime it's very difficult for people
to do certain things now without being
filmed
so i think we're getting better at
surveillance
but we're not perfect in surveillance
but to reward the people that are doing
it right is something we should continue
doing
and that's of course what the institute
is doing
this remark you made there about how
cheaper
and cheaper and more accessible powerful
tech in the hands of
people who for whatever reason have a
grudge can be very dangerous
that that echoes so beautifully
what you matthew once once told me
was the key argument you made when you
convinced henry kissinger and richard
nixon to ban
bioweapons about cheap cheap weapons you
want to share that with
with the whole group here how you
persuaded them what happened
completely by accident not in the case
of victors don off who
did this by will in my case it was
accident
i was working for the government in the
summer of 1963 and i was given a tour
of fort dietrich and we came to a big
building which had a 10
000 liter fermenter and i asked my guide
a very nice man what do we do there and
he said we make anthrax spores
and i asked him why do we need that and
he said
it's cheaper than nuclear weapons it's a
strategic
weapon that much cheaper we can save a
lot of money
and i took a taxi cab to get back to my
office in the state department
and it dawned on me wait we don't want
to have 10
cent nuclear weapons why would we want
to have cheap
biological weapons if they're so
potentially potent
i got back to my office my office mate
was freeman dyson
who i had taken my first quantum
mechanics for and he gave me great
encouragement which was very
so i resolved that i made a protocol
like the way we do in the laboratory
what would be needed to get rid of this
program
and the answer was only the president
could do it so what's how do you get to
him and then
you write the details of the protocol
and i spent the next 10 years just
popping
the protocol but since i was fortunate
enough
to be at harvard and to have an
administration that was still
affected by jack kennedy's presidency
from harvard i was able to talk to
anybody whose door i knocked on
and little by little everybody came to
see we don't want to
pioneer a cheap weapon of mass
destruction
we want more to be so expensive that
nobody could afford it
but certainly not for everybody to be
able to afford it
that's good that's such a but you can't
do that with other problems
this is a very special case so for those
of you who just joined
now you can really understand why
matthew meselson got the
last year's future of life award and
we're so grateful to you you're
a true hero for us all and when you say
something about vaccines
it's certainly important to have good
vaccines for certain things
but don't forget the vector we don't
have black death anymore
we don't have a vaccination against
pastorella pestis
we just don't have a lot of rats and
lice
so it's important to control the rats
and the lice
and the mosquitoes etc etc and even the
air we breathe
in the case of things that are
transmitted as aerosols
all of those things can be done by a
kind of engineering but that's not
vaccines
although vaccines are important but a
very expensive way to go
thank you thank you so much matt now
continuing on this
this theme here about things we might
worry about
you you jennifer are you i
can't see you anymore are you still here
i'm sorry jennifer i had to go max i
apologize oh okay
okay great so this is uh
so staying on this on this theme here of
of how how we can steer
this technology towards um good uses
we um you've mentioned something we need
to worry about a lot which is the
technology getting both very powerful
and then being very cheap and falling
into the wrong hands
um and you also so i'm curious
what concrete things what concrete
advice would you give
to any political leaders or other other
influential
folks about what we can do right now
to push things in in the right direction
would you like to have more
oversight of what's happening every
political leader
should find him or herself a group of at
least two or three
good scientists to be by their elbow
whenever they need them
they should get bill feige to be
for example whoever is the president 10
years from now
should have a small quarterly of good
scientists
who are also good friends who can be
called up on the phone at any time
that one step would get a lot
accomplished
wonderful since uh
since viktor donov cannot be with us
today and speak with his his own voice
today
i'm very curious if for example you
michael have any anecdotes about your
father that you
you would like to share with us to make
it a little bit more personal
so we can all help us all get to know
him
[Music]
well uh yes
there was a lot of anecdotes uh
but he i i should say immediately that
that in his uh
in his personal life he didn't really
talked too much about uh smallpox
eradication or
uh other kind of accomplishments uh
that he had uh with us the family
he he uh kind of left it to his
uh his kind of research
and i mean he was always involved in in
science in researching
in uh reading papers writing books and
all these
things and basically the only
uh thing that we heard as a family
about uh about his his
kind of efforts to to eradicate
diseases fight diseases and things like
that
was when he invited friends and
and visitors and colleagues to our house
our apartment and they
were kind of discussing it and then we
as a family could
hear that and in this respect i just
remember there was a
visit from the american uh uh
delegation and it included a lot of
uh famous uh scientists
uh and uh i believe uh howard termin was
was there at that time and
a lot of other kind of people i didn't
know
i only heard of them later on when i
developed as a researcher
so uh and they were kind of uh
talking about viruses and
uh and basically and at that time i i
just remember
that they were discussing the
how the viruses can can become a
part of of a human
kind of body and it was obvious for
retroviruses of course but
but uh victor was very
uh kind of interested in in
in he was kind of proposing this idea
that this can can
happen with other viruses as well that
they can become
part of of the
human cells and affect our
kind of immunity and other things and i
believe that
that's a a very interesting idea that
never was fully developed and i believe
that
now people come to to
kind of think about that more and more
thank you so much for sharing that
and speaking of anecdotes um
bill do you want to share with with
our listeners here also the the story
about that amazing dinner
which i thought really drove home and
the
all the the richness of the
international
us soviet collaboration
yes thank you max um victor came
for a week to visit us at cdc
along with dr benedictof
and the two of them spent the entire
week going program by program at
cdc they found it so interesting
always asking questions taking notes on
the last
night in atlanta we put out a dinner for
them at stone mountain
and the state department required
the state officers to actually come to
atlanta
because these were such important
visitors benedict off
in victor so they sent two people from
the state department
they sent down the surgeon general
julius richmond
and so we had a nice dinner after dinner
i got up and i proposed some toast
the first toast that i proposed was i
would like to toast the soviet army
and with that the state department
people
absolutely lost all the blood in their
face
and they sat there not knowing what's
going to happen next
both benedictof and victor
looked uneasy what's coming next
and the only person that was sanguine
was
julius richmond the surgeon general he
didn't know what i was going to say but
he was okay with whatever i said
so i said that i would toast the soviet
army because
the person at the table who was the
deputy director at cdc bill watson
had been in a pow camp during the second
world
and he had watched the destruction
of german cities he was very
emotionally involved in this and then he
was liberated by the soviet army
and i pointed out what this meant to the
health of americans
what it meant to the health of people in
the world and
everybody breathed the sigh of relief
and i remember benedict off then getting
up and saying
i couldn't make a toast like that
without you having done it first
but he said now i'm going to tell you
what i would tell pravda
and so he then told a similar story
but it was a very nice night and it it
was actually
a demonstration of what happened in this
program
with soviets and americans working side
by side
and in india i actually supervised
soviets who in turn supervised americans
now you can't imagine that happening
during the cold war
in other any other program but it shows
what's possible in health
and it says to me we should figure out
how to
exploit this how to use health problems
as surrogates for an alien invasion
that it just we all have to be involved
in finding the solutions
thank you for that now we know that uh
you bill have not only a very big brain
and a very big heart but also a very
equally big sense of humor
and uh it's so great to hear you talk
about
international collaboration that is best
here today because
looking here in the chat we have people
listening right now
from china from russia from romania
the uk sweden canada norway
austria italy new zealand and as far
away and azerbaijan and other places so
hopefully this is also something we can
learn from again if it could be done
then
it can probably be done again and bill
we have another question here directly
from our live audience which is
specifically directed at you they're
wondering how did you get into smallpox
in the first place
well the i was with the epidemic
intelligence service
at cdc and i was stationed in denver
colorado
i got a call one noon saying that there
was a suspected
case of smallpox in a child
in the navajo nation in new mexico
and that they'd already made a
reservation on a plane for me to
fly there that evening and they
suggested i
get a book written by dixon on smallpox
so i went to the medical library found
out it was
checked out to a medical student who was
writing a paper on smallpox
i was able to find him and he did not
want to give up the book
because he was writing a paper and it
took some real
political persuasion to get that book
out of his hands
but i quickly went through the relevant
parts of it
so that i felt i knew the difference
between chickenpox and smallpox anyway
not on that plane and i was totally
uh surprised to find that there was a
car that drove right to the plane as it
stopped
before we got to the terminal and they
had me get off
as they took me to the hospital and then
i found that there were people waiting
at the hospital for the quotes outside
expert
on smallpox to examine the child
and as i entered that room i knew from
the door
before i ever got to the bedside that i
had no idea what that child had
and it turned out to be a very confusing
situation
of a child recovering from measles and
then having disseminated herpes on top
of that
and then to make it worse it's one of
only two
errors that i have known about in
smallpox lab work at cdc
where they originally diagnosed it as
compatible with smallpox so
we went through some difficult days
but it piqued my interest and the next
year
i went to india as part of a cdc
project and saw smallpox for the first
time
and i was impressed with what a terrible
disease this is as i saw even the
workers at the hospital
were reluctant to touch the patient
and he realized how those patients felt
now
alienated from the world so that even if
they recovered
and they had pock marks that's the
feeling they were going to have is that
they were alienated
from the world so it turned out to be an
emotional thing with me
of being interested in smallpox because
of that first case
eventually i i read in your book also
though you got
so good at diagnosing small parts at a
glance that you couldn't even help
yourself from
look by seeing people's pock marks as
you walk through the streets of india
and other places and there was a very
emotional thing you mentioned there
about how
that evolved over the years do you want
to share that
well over the years i came to realize
you could actually smell
smallpox before you entered the room and
so
if i would be starting now with smallpox
eradication
one of the first things i would do is
train dogs
because they would be able to pick this
up much faster than humans
if i would be starting now on smallpox
eradication i probably wouldn't be
because as michael knows that with
hiv it changed everything we actually
eradicated small epoxy
during a window of opportunity and if we
had waited until
hiv came along we would have had immune
problems
that would have made it difficult to do
the kind of vaccination programs we did
fantastic so we're soon going to give
our
guests of honor here the last word let
me
say something in closing before we do
that though
i i want to um this is a very bad habit
that professors have
can't help assigning homework this is
homework for all of you out there
listening to this your homework
the way you can contribute is by letting
us know who should get
the future life award in the future
don't worry
if you're not completely sure we take
all the nominations and subject them to
very careful scientific scrutiny and so
on
but if you nominate next year's winner
we will give you
three thousand dollars just as a token
of appreciation
and the uh and
if you tell someone else about this and
then they nominate the winner you will
give them
we'll give you fifteen hundred and then
three thousand so we wanna really
crowdsource
and get all the good ideas because some
of the greatest heroes out there
i believe are so unsung that almost
nobody
has heard about them um i also want to
before we give you all the last word
here
say some word of thanks first of all
again to
john talin friend and co-founder of the
future life is dude and also
the very generous guy thanks to whom
we're actually able to give you
prize money thank you yan
you're amazing i also want to thank the
amazing team
here at the future life institute who
has worked very hard
for a very long time to make all this
possible
deeming love and appreciation at you all
and now and
finally for the rest of you who are
listening to this if you would like to
hear a little bit more or learn a bit
more about our great heroes
please go to futurelife.org and go to
the page about this award
you will find there a fascinating
podcast
that lucas perry has recorded with
really
interesting interviews with all of the
winners here today
you will find this never previously
existing in english book about victor
janov
you'll find links to bill's amazing book
and so on
this is a journey that can continue for
a long time but for now
let me turn to first
of all um
victor's done of junior do you want to
say a few words just couple words
regarding this rewards well um
i'm really proud um
want to say to how much i'm proud to get
this award for my father
and unfortunately i was very young in
the time
my father was working on this smallpox
eradication
and dolphin had no time even for me and
for my brother but
now i understand that it was to save
millions of lives
and i want to say thank you very much
i'm very proud to take this award for my
father and thank you again
and thank you thank you for continuing
the
legacy there and um michael
do you want to say a few words
yes i want to join my brother and
thank the future of life institute
and especially uh for your
uh kind of recognition
of victor donov's lifelong
efforts to engage international
cooperation
in fighting world diseases and i think
that that's
the key point to our future
success in fighting infections
thank you so much and uh bill you're
going to get the last word
for this live stream thank you max
first i to have a professor assign
homework
uh reminds me that when i gave a
commencement address
at a college once i said why do we have
commencement addresses
because the passion to teach surpasses
the passion to learn
and so teachers will give you homework
right till the end
but let me say that um i
i'm so pleased with this award but i'm
particularly pleased
that you've made it international made
the point that this was international
and that it was possible because of a
problem
that politics could not interfere with
so
even in the cold war we had the soviets
and the americans working together
it becomes a great example of how we
should do things in the future thank you
so much
what a great way to summarize what this
is all about
thank you so much all of you huge
congratulations
to our winners and i hope all of you who
are listening
feel inspired by this and go out and do
great things
to make a great future of life
thank you goodbye
could i stay connected with
bill i liked you
oops michael you're